only on c-span 2
created by the cable television industry
next
in-depth
with tony morrison
toni morrison's first book the bluest
eye was published in 1970 when she was
nearly 40 years old
over the next 30 years tony morrison
published six more novels and numerous
works of nonfiction
her writing has received all of the
literary world's highest honors the
national book critics award the national
book foundation medal the pulitzer and
in 1993 the nobel prize for literature
and through all of this ms morrison has
continued to teach new generations of
writers from her base at princeton
university for the next three hours we
are pleased to have with us toni
morrison for an in-depth conversation
about her life's work
toni morrison as we begin i've seen
several citations that you've told
people that it's
easiest best most apt to describe you as
a black woman novelist is that correct
absolutely and what are we
the public to take away from your choice
of those three words
i think it was a an attempt on my part
to refuse to be given the status of
honorary white male writer
generally speaking women's work has been
reduced to regional
or merely
or
people compliment ethnic writers by
saying or implying
that they are as good as mainstream
writers
and whereas i understood the compliment
i thought it would be better for me at
least in the late 60s and early 70s
to establish once and for all that all
three of those things play
i'm black i am a woman and i'm a writer
and they go together
you've also always been a teacher yes
why is that been important to who you
are and what you do
well i
didn't quite know what else to do when i
graduated because my first love was
books
so i thought i would choose a position
or a job where i taught them
and had to read them and had to explain
them to others
and university teaching was the
thing i loved the most that i still do
after all these years and all these
other kinds of jobs i've had i've always
taught since i'm
26 years old
who first instilled in you the love of
reading
well you know i'm not quite sure
i know that i don't remember
myself
unable to read
i don't remember being a person i know i
read some time before i went
to the first grade and i am assuming
that came from my
sister who was a year and a half older
but i sort of always knew
how to do that activity and i remember
very clearly being
the only student in the first grade
class who could read
but i thought it was because the others
weren't interested
i lived in a very
loving chaotic noisy
full of music
and argument and comings in goings house
and in that environment the only privacy
there was was in books
so i developed this
obsession i think with that form of
escape for those of you who are new to
our in-depth series it is really that we
will have the opportunity to spend three
full hours with tony morrison and let me
tell you a little bit about how the
process will work we will be talking
here for about the next 15 minutes and
then our phone lines and email will be
open for you to send in comments and
questions that's really the beauty of
the process is that we hear your
questions and what thoughts you have on
your mind so as we converse here the way
to phone in and the way to email us will
be on the bottom of our television
screen and we do welcome your
participation in this process overall
tell me and i know you've done this
hundreds of times but tell me the story
of lorraine ohio
lorraine ohio is a um
was not quite sure what it is now
working class town
on lake erie
my parents appeared there in the early
around world war one shortly after
i had mills
uh shipyards steel mills
and it was home to immigrants
east europeans
mexicans
black people from the south
i'm born in the 30s so i remember it as
a depression town
uh
and then later during world war ii was a
booming
town but my formative opinion of it was
this incredible place
with all the best parts of
what ohio had to offer those people who
were in the mode of the abolitionists
you know oberlin university is just
up the road a little bit which was
the first college to have women and
blacks attended
and so it was a melting pot
really and truly because there were so
few schools one high school
four junior high schools we all lived in
and among each other
i never lived on any block in which
there were no other white people
all those churches and social lives were
frequently separate
and i thought that's the way most people
live but i learned later
it was certainly not the case
fascinating place to be from i have to
tell you how much connection do you have
with it today quite a bit my sister
and her family i have nieces and nephews
who still live there and my mother
hasn't been dead that long and she
was there all her life
so i have very strong family connections
when one looks at your family story your
biography it it struck me at least
that the almost the entire story of
black experience in america is contained
in three generations in your family
grandfather slave to sharecropper father
and mother the great migration to the
north and yourself first generation
college and a great success
oh that sounds fake
it sounds sort of formulaic in a way but
i guess you're right
for me it just seems
enormously a long long time
from my grandfather being born
he was five years old
when emancipation proclamation was
declared when he was born in 1860
right
and he was crying he was frightened
because he kept hearing the adults
say it's coming it's coming
uh emancipation proclamation is coming
he thought it was a monster so he
crawled under the bed and they had to
pull him out and explain to him it was a
good thing
and i'm very keenly aware of the
really life-threatening circumstances
under which they lived the difficulties
my parents had as young as a young
couple
um and a kind of a miraculous thing i
suppose in my generation
i just knew i really wanted to go to
college my mother was not
interested
in my getting married she didn't think
that was
necessarily the ultimate goal of a
woman's life or rather she thought it
shouldn't come too soon
so she and my father were very
supportive and they told me listen
we don't have enough
for you to get
a full college education but we do have
enough for one year
and i said that's all i wanted just one
year
so that's the way i went
off convinced that i could survive
financially for one year
in 1949
50.
and of course i was able to work and do
the rest myself
but that's how iffy it was in those days
about getting
you know
a college education not just for
african-americans but for women
in general oh yeah how did you finance
the rest of the of your education how
were you working
oh i had
temporary jobs
while i was in washington this is at
howard university where i was an
undergraduate
and
actually my mother got a job
she was so happy that i was here i guess
since college
so she took a job at night
as a woman in the ladies room
collects the tips
and she made 15
a week five dollars a night
and she sent it to me
she did that in ohio
how did
chloe
wofford your birth name become tony
morrison
oh a little bit of lunacy i think
and some vanity
people my name is chloe
i love the name
children couldn't pronounce it
some adults would fuse to renounce
pronounce it
and they called me chilo
or
khloe
or
other things that were not chloe
and my family because my sister and i
were so close in age
they called and we were always together
they called us lois and chloe
so i didn't really have
a separate syllabus for myself at any
rate to make a long story short when i
got away to um
howard
um
i used the name tony which was a short
informed of my saints name anthony
so there i was tony wofford most of the
people knew me as tony orphan
and then subsequently my
ex-husband's name morrison
you uh married and became a mother
and were you writing at this point in
your life
i didn't i think i was but i wasn't
i certainly didn't call myself a writer
i was a teacher and i was interested in
uh
the work of some local people here in
washington some were faculty members
uh some were
artists
and
they had a group of writers that they
formed and i was invited to attend and i
brought with me some
you know sort of frail little things
that i had worked on as a very young
person
and one of them was a little story that
i had to write fresh
because they wouldn't let me come
over and over again if i didn't bring
anything new so i wrote a story
and brought it to that meeting and
used it much later as the heart
of the first novel i wrote
and it was called
the bluest eye i'd like to show it to
the audience and
as i do would you explain how this book
actually made it to print from that that
beginning
well i um
wrote the story for the club
i remember my baby my oldest son was
hanging on my
shoulder pulling at my earrings while i
was writing and i remember him spitting
up on the manuscript
some orange juice and i always tell the
story it must be important because i
didn't wipe it out right away i wrote
around it
and then wiped it up and stopped
and then
went to the meeting had a good time
heard some serious criticism of it
some delight and that was it
and then later on several years later
when i was in another place
not teaching anymore but working at a
publishing house i began to work it up
and then i sent it around to
i think 12 or 14 publishers
before
somebody was interested enough to take
it who said yes um
holt alan
sinsler
it was at
holt reinhardt in winston do you still
remember either the letter or the phone
call
that said yes we'll take this there's a
phone call
there's so many phone calls about oh i
wish i could take this book but i don't
think
they will
i'll try
that's what i remember
and then suddenly i'm sitting at my desk
in a random house
and i got a phone call
that said
they said yes
i remember that
from
simply a point of view of your artistry
if one were to
read this book
and your latest most recent novel
paradise
what would you find different about your
style about your approach to words into
literature
i think the most for me the striking
thing is that the person who wrote the
bluest eye
that voice
that uh quality
is exists in paradise also
that's very important to me and odd to
have a style
immediately not to have to develop one i
had to learn how to write better
uh how to seduce a reader faster
how to challenge a reader how to open up
the world uh how to manipulate but what
i'm pleased about
and i didn't know it until i wrote the
second book sula was that i really and
truly do have
a recognizable style if i took one page
out of any of those books and read it
i think i would know it was me
and not somebody else and i think that's
true of readers who know my work
for people who know you but haven't yet
read your work can you put some words to
that style and to the stories that
you're trying to tell
the style probably it's ineffable at the
moment but it's a kind of welcoming
style the voice is welcoming
and doesn't blink
and tells you very difficult things
but in a voice that makes it all right
to hear
this is not going to be an easy trip
the journey is going to be bumpy but i'm
going to tell you the truth and you can
hear it
because i've already been there and i'm
holding your hand
and you can go with me it's going to be
all right
that's the voice that's the comfort
level the stories are
funny sad
odd combinations
that reveal the complexity
and the profundity
and the
size of human life
sometimes we live so small
i mean in our imaginations i don't mean
wealth and status
we live small frightened lives
and
sometimes the people in the books do but
generally speaking
the most important thing that happens is
that their lives are larger
and that they learn something at the end
of the book
that but for the book they never would
have learned
let me take a minute to give people the
telephone number so they can join the
conversation if you live in the eastern
half of the united states the number to
reach toni morrison is
202-737-001 if you live in the western
half the mountain of pacific time zones
our number here is 202-737-002
and we'll begin taking telephone calls
in about five more minutes
if you would indulge me and i should
have asked you this before we went live
on camera but i i thought maybe that we
could hear your voice through a little
bit of
of your work and i was struggling what
to choose and i decided upon
really the operative
moment within
beloved now first will you tell the
story of or just give us a quick
synopsis of of beloved
beloved is a story based on a
historical figure of a
black
woman who
killed her children or tried to
when she was a fugitive and didn't want
to return to slavery
beloved is about
her life as imagined by me significantly
altered by the return
of
what she believes to be
the daughter she killed
we pick it up when the
fugitive slave act is about to be
enforced with the picking up
of this group of people by the sheriff
and others not too long the sheriff
turned
the sheriff turned then said to the
other three you better go on
look like your business is over
minds started now
school teacher beat his hat against his
thigh and spit
before living in the woodshed nephew and
the catcher backed out with him
they didn't look at the woman in the
pepper plants with the flower in her hat
and they didn't look at the seven or so
faces
that had edged closer in spite of the
catcher's rifle warning
enough
to share
enough [ __ ] eyes for now
little [ __ ] boy eyes open and saw dust
little [ __ ] girl eyes
staring between the wet fingers
that held her face
so her head wouldn't fall off
little [ __ ] baby eyes
crinkling up to cry in the arms of the
old
in the arms of the old [ __ ] whose own
eyes were nothing but slivers looking
down at his feet
but the worst ones
were those of the [ __ ] woman
who looked like she didn't have any
since the whites in them had disappeared
and since they were as black as her skin
she looked blind
they unhitched from school teacher's
horse the borrowed mule that was to
carry the fugitive woman back to where
she belonged
and tied into the fans
then with the sun straight up over their
heads they trotted off leaving the
sheriff behind
among the damnedest bunch of coons
they'd ever seen
all testimony to the results of a little
so-called freedom
imposed on people who needed every care
and indulgence
in the world to keep them from
the cannibal life
they
preferred you chose an interesting one
my efforts to think
the way
committed
slaveholders
think
the naturalness
of their contempt
the effortlessness
of their belief
in their superiority to these
people
coming in the book at a moment
after the reader has been in the lives
of these people who they have
categorized as
[ __ ] woman [ __ ] man [ __ ]
baby [ __ ] boy
but because these characters are so
familiar
and intimately portrayed this
i was hoping
section that i read
comes with a chill
not just because of the events of the
slaughter
but the way in which at this point
your they are looked at
how do you get inside the psyches of
these people
it's difficult but i use what i think
are methods that
maybe actors and actresses use
when you read when you have a vague
character or you try to make it specific
fully realized and you want to be in
that person's
head if you're on stage
to wear the clothes
wear the shoes
behave the way that person would
so you have to enter
or project
and know
you know where they park their hair and
what kind of soap they would wear and
what food they don't like
whether or not it appears
in the book you try to imagine all those
things and that works for me
i can uh
suspend
i mean i don't judge my characters that
way
uh whether i want to have lunch with
them or not is something quite different
but you have to love
them for the moment of their portrayal
whether they are men women
old young
children what have you
and are they sprung from your pen fully
formed or they do they develop as you
write
as you sit down and this book comes out
do you already know the story you're
going to tell i frequently know the
questions the story
is supposed to answer
or i'm provoked as i was by margaret
garner what must that feel like
or in paradise to hear about those
people who
walked all that distance to get to
free black towns and were turned away by
black people
who had also been slaves like them and
they were not welcome there i thought my
god what that must feel like so i know
what the story is about i sort of know
the journey now i have to find out who's
going to work that out for me
margaret garner i didn't want to know
too much about her
what she looked like etc i wanted to
invent her so i only need just a few
strokes
to start and then i you know sort of put
them together so they are never
fully realized immediately they always
take currying and coddling and stroking
and
personal introductions and
anything i can do to get them to
speak and trust me
as you can see our lines are lighted up
here let's take our first telephone call
for you it's from richmond virginia
welcome to our conversation you're on
the air
hi
yes miss morrison um first of all i want
to thank you for writing the book song
of solomon it has been one of those
momentous occasions for me
in my life um i had an opportunity to be
at your first reading for paradise at
the abbey city and baptist church in
harlem yes a couple of years ago
and um i wanted to know you made a
statement at that particular time that
you felt that books should remain books
when someone asks you about your
excitement about putting all of your
book into movies into plays and since
that time you've had one of your books
beloved produced into a major motion
picture
which i particularly was disappointed in
but it still enjoyed the book and and
still had to go back to the book and
wanted to know would you would you in in
the future hold more
artistic control over
your books being
put into another generation
thank you
sure we understand thank you
no i won't
i don't want artistic control
over
other genre being developed from my
books
i really do believe that books
are singular
maybe they don't have to remain books
but they certainly are books and if
they're made subsequently into movies
good movies mediocre movies great movies
whatever
that's another thing that's another art
form and the book has to stand
on the shelf
by itself and it's a special kind of of
pleasure in it
the reason i don't want autistic control
is because
i am a very controlling person
when i work and i
if i'm not going to make the movie
produce it
choose everybody fund it then i don't
want to be involved in it as a kind of
consultant without power and without
knowledge because i don't know how to
make movies and i don't know how to
write screenplays
and i don't want to learn how to do that
either
i respect the people who do
and i
give them whatever information
they solicit from me but no i don't want
final cut on these things unless i own
the whole shop
our next question is an email
comes from conseta lee who is a teacher
at sea breeze high school and it is
about beloved she writes your novel
beloved enriches my 12th grade honors
english class tremendously so my
questions are related to its text i'm
interested in knowing the significance
of the parallel structure you
implemented in the final chapter it was
not a story to pass on it was not a
story to pass on and this is not a story
to pass on additionally my students
often inquire whether beloved is
physically pregnant they seem to
conclude that she is actually carrying
paul d's baby personally i tried them
that they have watched one too many soap
operas
well your students are ahead of you this
time
in a way i wanted beloved to be both
things i wanted her to be
the returned child
that sethe longed for and her daughter
denver longed for they really need her
to come back
and say
let them work out their expiations
on her but at the same time the buried
scene
concerns the middle passage
maybe this girl is a survivor
of the middle passage traumatized by it
kept
locked up somewhere is freed with only
the memories of what that must have been
like
and for me the two things came together
resurrection from the dead
in order to
demand love which could be the dead baby
resurrection from
slave ship
journeys
in order to demand love
those two stories seem to me to be
parallel
so i never came down on one side or the
other but there's a clear indication
that beloved is a historical figure
rather than the
ghost-like figure
next telephone calls from hampton
virginia
yes this question is about song with
solomon i've had two questions about the
book
one how did you come up with the great
strategy of the water stain on the table
to be a physicality of
uh milkman's mother
memory for her of her past life and then
the other thing is this
it seems to be the first book where
there's a male protagonist and wanted to
know what was that shift for you from
going from a female protagonist to a
male protagonist thank you
um
i searched around a little bit for
something
quiet and unobtrusive but persistent and
a bit of a mar
to explain
something about the characterization of
milkman's mother and the water stain you
know if you're a housekeeper you know
they're just impossible to remove
uh and they are not an overwhelming or
dramatic
mark what's one that you keep working at
it seemed good and domestic for her the
shift to writing
about men was a
mighty shift i thought it would be not
so difficult because i'd written cameos
with men
in them before but to have the book
[ __ ]
driven by
men was far more complicated than i
thought it would be and i had to rely
for entrance into that
imaginative world on my father my uncles
and men i knew and trying to see
or render
how they saw the world
i think also i was unprepared
for the impact that women had on their
lives it's not it wasn't just male
bonding but i can assure you it was a
very powerful
and different
imaginative process that i had to
go through to center that book on
male protagonists
excuse me your fans know these books
well but for those who don't i'm going
to work in a few photos about some of
the books as we talk about song of
solomon 1977
and it is set for the most part in
michigan 1930s through 1960s
and for you and your own career this was
the first of your books to make the best
seller list
yes it's true and it had a rebirth when
it was selected by oprah about 20 years
later it's true
she's selected as one of her book club
choices and it sold more as a
consequence of that than it had in its
entire history even though it was a very
successful publication what do you think
of the work that she is doing with the
book club
what's made an enormous difference
uh i think even when i was in publishing
for over 20 years that was what we were
always
hoping would happen not just the best
sellers which takes a certain amount of
you know
work uh but just have reading
um
by your everyday books interesting books
become a habit a profound habit
not among
you know the collectors or the academics
but every day
work
of
taking the time
to read a book
and being able to argue about it debate
it quarrel about it disagree with it
that is what i think oprah's book club
has introduced
i feel that uh
even here on c-span part of the whole
notion of having
just conversations with authors about
books
on television
is novel and people enjoy it
people do it local newspapers have their
own book clubs
and there are book clubs
in neighborhood book clubs
all over this country i don't give her
full credit for all of that but i
certainly have to give her a large
portion of it for making it okay to turn
off the television and read a book
coming back to
this particular book song of solomon the
caller referenced the protagonist who
has the very unusual last name of the
dead
how did that come about
well there was some problem
with friedman's bureau when this
slave
tries to give him
information he says were you born
your parents living or dead etc and the
man was a little drunk and he put all
this information in the wrong space so
his name is
macon dead
his first name was where he was born his
parents become his last name etc next
telephone call for tony morrison is from
san diego welcome you're on the air
yes uh tommy let me just turn this video
down
um
tony i'm taking license you i listened
to your um
discussion on the event of kino actually
seventh birthday and uh
my name was ben and cook when we knew
each other
um
and cook yes
howard university yes now now taiko
quien i was at columbia at the time and
you were doing
toni kate bamara's first book black
female voices i had an essay in there
and i you were seeing
how uh you regret it that
since you've
attained celebrity status there's been a
sort of a
difference in treatment that people
you've known
uh have given to you but i'm calling now
because i want to salute you not only
for your prevailing but for your
enduring
uh and let me just tell you why my my
you are our symbol
of the sikh program that we had at city
college of new york at the time
and um
tony kate bammer was a part of that
she's now in a tr made her transition so
has barbara christian and james emanuel
henry dumas and audrey lord and just
yesterday through our mutual friend dean
allen ballot we found that still another
person from that
program
mcdonald has made his transition
and
that program
was so important to us and and did so
much in terms of
reshaping how
universities should uh bring in people
and what the curriculum should include
and now the irony of irony city college
has gone back to his old tradition of
of closing off those options and so when
i
see you when i hear you i remember those
times in your office and also remember
the fact that we need to get back to the
kind of offerings
that we had during that rich period of
the 60s well we will as long as you do
it's really wonderful to hear from you
great i have to tell you and it's nice
seeing you and again continue enduring
the prevailing you've done we hope we
wish you health so that you can continue
my students at city college at the san
diego city schools here
have been just enthralled by what you
have written in particular with that
video that was done to accompany your
readings on from beloved uh that was
done by london television it opened a
lot of eyes on youngsters who have no
idea what slavery was like thank you
thanks for that call actually a lot
there you can take that phone call in
lots of directions for our larger larger
audience um two of the notes i wrote
down was about you and dealing with
celebrity status you want to talk a
little bit about that
uh well i think i was a little
overconfident and very arrogant when i
began to be well known
or known at all because i was a
middle-aged woman i didn't publish i
didn't write and said i was 39 years old
so i had already formed a personality
i was an adult i was a mother i had a
full-time job
and so the
vulnerability
of
celebrity hood
was
i was never interested in it it had of
no interest to me whatsoever
uh i felt my work was extremely valuable
and that whenever people complimented me
that's what they were complimenting so
it seemed perfectly wonderful to me it
didn't have anything to do with the
person who lived inside
now
so i was
mindful of other people's alterations
expectations
changes
um the delight you can bring as well as
the resentment
as well as the uses to which people can
make a view
i was a took authors around i know how
that works you know how you was a
publicist as a publicist and as an
editor i know how to solicit the press
and how to manipulate it etc
and and i see authors successful or not
successful in working with their
readership so i thought i was pretty
good at the whole thing but suddenly in
the late years and very recently
maybe it's post-nobel prize it's not
really that i think it's after
being a couple of times on oprah winfrey
show
and i felt
more and more the disadvantages
which always exist
uh of being well known then the
advantages
the advantages are overwhelming
i get to have a powerful active
readership
large
i get to be published in 28 languages
and
people really know my work and really
quarrel about it and that is ideal you
can't ask for anything
better than that
on the other hand
it has other problems
i
dismissed them all because they were of
no consequence to me
now i have to
do something else
i have to
guard myself or prepare myself
for other people
i've never done that in my life
i've always been
whatever it was
always open
or closed based on something was going
on in me not about somebody outside and
that is it just sounds whiny to me to go
on about that and it is whiny
but the problem exists when it comes in
to the study
there was always the free place
for me
nobody was in there but me
my characters
and the language
now when that begins to be
meddled with
then i am in trouble
and it hasn't happened
but i feel threatened
and it's something that no one has to
deal with it's not the public this is me
and i was sort of disappointed in myself
in responding to this celebrityhood
another interesting
line of inquiry there is the whole
curriculum question at universities but
why don't we come back to that a little
bit later on take a call from omaha
yes caller yes i'm just uh calling
because i'm so fascinated with mrs
morrison uh there are some things in our
lives that are quite similar i was born
in the 30s and uh one of seven girls
and our uh home was pretty much like
hers
we would walk
we all loved books and we would walk for
miles over the railroad tracks going to
the libraries and my place to read was
under the bed
i just want to commend her on the most
amazing
gift that she has
i went to see
beloved with my daughter who teaches
black history also uses one of her books
the bluest eye
but one of the things that i wanted to
call about about beloved was to tell her
how moving it was for her to portray
slavery in the way that she did
and i was just fascinated
with her deep spiritual gift
and how did she come about casting out
that
spirit out of beloved we were just
absolutely in awe and i can't understand
unless you really understand what she
how she
um
that had to come up really deep out of
your soul so would you just comment on
that sure
um i wasn't sure whether she was asking
about
beloved coming out of my soul or oprah's
but i will tell you the former
um
i was thinking really not about slavery
i was thinking about the ways in which
women
love everything more than themselves
their children their husbands their
nurturing qualities were so profound
and
we were being asked to give those up in
order to make greater choices as
liberated women you know to be more
selfish
and that argument between the selfless
nurturing woman and the selfish
narcissistic woman that line was very
close it was difficult to negotiate
that's really what i was thinking about
and then i thought
you know we're being encouraged to take
motherhood as a choice we don't have to
have children we don't have to yearn for
children and maybe freedom is not having
children
then i thought
but for certain women to be able
to be responsible for their children
was the most freedom
the most identity
the most dangerous thing that they could
do
and those were slave women
whose children they did not own
they could have the child but it wasn't
theirs it could be sold at any moment
taken away at any age
so to actually have
your child bear it
and
be responsible for it
was an act of such revolutionary
proportions
it casts a long shadow on contemporary
urgings vis-a-vis
a woman's place
so
the story that i had just read a
newspaper article about
about this woman who
said no i'm not doing that this child is
mine her life is mine
she's my child
i will see how she lives and dies
and of course it was a crime
and it was a sin
but on the other hand it was this other
gesture
it was
complicated
and that's how i began doing the
research on that concept in slavery
this might be an interesting time to mix
this book into it but you know i have to
tell you i've been struggling with the
meaning of this and as you bring up some
of the themes of freedom and also
responsibility of motherhood maybe you
can help explain it to me first of all
what's the project
somebody asked me did i have any
children's stories and i said no
but i did have a story that my son and i
slayed morrison
when he was a little kid
had some
unpleasantness with the teacher
disciplinary and she had said to him
you have no idea how to use your freedom
and it hurt him so much
so we wrote that it was i rhymed it and
he was complaining about it and then
later
lo these many years later
i submitted it to hyperion and they
liked it and we use it as a children's
book but it's
it's a little sly as you can tell
the kids seem to love it and understand
it it's in six different languages now
but it is about freedom and about how
personal that is and in fact the parents
in this story give their children up to
another authority they give them things
they just want them happy they don't
want to talk to them they don't want to
wrestle with them they want them over
there
with all their toys all their
playstations all their goodies pictures
of the sky pictures of the sea but no
real engagement and the children are
begging in all these various
environments
for an opportunity to just be
free whatever that meant in their own
way if you were to sit with a child in
your lap and read this aloud
how would you
talk to them about the issues and themes
inside this book oh i would only read it
and let them in my inestimable
loving voice and
it's like a
song the kids get it instantly
they know i mean we really do
underestimate
the brilliant little kids we test them
and we see them do ballet we think
that's where they're smart that's not
they don't understand language they have
to find out from all sorts of ways what
you really mean children know when
they're being bought
by their parents with toys
they know when they're being
you know given no freedom whatsoever
under the guise of freedom they
understand it fully and if you don't
think so all you have to do is remember
what you knew
when you were that age
you knew when the smiles were fake
you knew when people walked in the room
and rather you left
you knew when you were being dismissed
even while people were embracing you
that reading that children give is very
much a survival instinct in them
ventura california for toni morrison
uh good morning miss morrison good
morning it's i appreciate the
opportunity to talk with you
i'm going to shut off my set here
um
i'm
coming up on my 73rd birthday and
starting to mess around with writing
which is what i always wanted to do when
i grew up
i had been a systems consultant for many
years and wrote many consulting reports
and this is a genre that is not
generally considered literature to say
the least
i'm very interested
i
not intending to flatter you but it's
obvious that you're a person of
considerable talent
and i'm interested in the subject of the
wellsprings of this talent
at my age i have a theory about almost
everything
and it's usually in three parts
and the
wellsprings of talons seem to me to be
certainly
a talent for storytelling
as isaac's
singer used to say i'm just a
storyteller you know
it's certainly a facility with language
but there seems to be an x factor an
unknown factor
complete the puzzle
and i was wondering what you think that
that x factor is in the case of talent
and if you have a different way of
structuring or thinking about talent
please
please convey that
to move from talent to success
the two are regrettably not
are regrettably less than perfectly
correlated but to move from that
there's the old question of inspiration
versus perspiration
and i wonder how you would weigh those
factors i'm going to hang now and turn
them back my television set back on
thank you thank you very much i think
well i think it's different for
different people i teach creative
writing and i'm always trying to get
students to recognize when they're at
their best where and under what
circumstances
for me it's compulsion
it's not discipline it's not even an
effort of the will
it's an inability to not do it
i just cannot not think that way and i
cannot for long
not
write
for me it's a kind of extension almost
of reading which i
did all my life and do
uh still
but it's
it's i am absolutely
happiest
and at my most
it's risky it's happy
it's difficult
it is absolutely the place i prefer to
be
is working out and solving
problems of fiction writing sentences
this word that word and everything i've
ever known
in the world
everything i've ever read bits and
pieces of that seem to come together and
are useful
in the construction of fiction for me
we still have two hours plus to go with
toni morrison lots more to talk about
her works both fiction and nonfiction
we're going to take a short break and
continue our conversation
in a moment we'll return to in-depth
with tony morrison